Trascrizione: Ilaria Marinozzi
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Grazie.
Buonasera a tutti.
Come vi è stato annunciato
non parlo qui da sindaco,
ma da quello che ho fatto nella mia vita
e continuo a farlo
perché è una delle professioni che,
secondo me, insieme alla medicina
salva il mondo in tutti i momenti
ma ha anche delle grandi criticità.
E oggi noi possiamo, come dire,
avere il cibo in tante forme.
Siamo vegani, siamo fruttariani,
siamo biologici, siamo biodinamici,
poi apprezziamo dei vini DOP o IGP.
Insomma, abbiamo tante varietà di cibo
che ci consentono di scegliere.
Ma non è stato sempre così.
Ma questo da quando è partito?
L’attività agricola è un’attività
che ha avuto una storia complessa,
ma che oggi occupa circa
15 miliardi di superficie nel mondo
e coltivata effettivamente,
ne viene coltivata circa 5 miliardi.
Però questa coltivazione
si è evoluta nel tempo.
E come?
Negli inizi degli anni del Novecento
si è parlato di un genetista
che ha trasformato soprattutto il grano
in una coltivazione molto produttiva
e quel grano
che oggi troviamo nella pasta
del famoso senatore Cappelli
è proprio di quel periodo.
È stato modificato, non modificato,
è stato selezionato geneticamente.
e sapete da dove proviene questa varietà?
Dalla Tunisia.
È stato modificato
nella stazione sperimentale di Foggia,
e da lì, quelle taglie alte che c’erano,
perché il grano veniva coltivato
a un metro e 60 addirittura
sono scese molto più basse.
Questo perché ha consentito
di abbassare sette quintali l’ettaro
a oltre oggi arriviamo anche
a 80, 100 quintali l’ettaro.
Che significa? Che abbiamo molta più
disponibilità di cibo.
E questo nell’evoluzione
di questa storia agricola,
che si è avuta in questi cento anni,
ha consentito addirittura
nel periodo alla fine degli anni ’70
di avere tanta produzione,
tantissima produzione,
che naturalmente incideva
fortemente sull’impatto ambientale.
Ed era così rilevante questo
impatto ambientale,
che in tutto il mondo si è deciso
di cominciare a pensare
a come migliorare questo rapporto
tra la produzione
e l’impatto sull’ambiente.
E quindi sono nate delle misure,
delle azioni,
che la genetica, come dire,
il carburante, che sono i concimi,
e un altro elemento oggi
a cui siamo molto attenti,
che sono i pesticidi,
li abbiamo cominciati a vedere
in modo diverso.
Perché? Perché oggi noi,
che siamo molto più attenti al cibo
e, in generale, quasi tutto il mondo,
anche nei luoghi
dove c’è meno disponibilità di cibo
c’è l’attenzione alla qualità.
E questa attenzione ci porta naturalmente
a spingere gli agricoltori
a produrre in maniera diversa.
Questa sensibilità ha portato quindi
a utilizzare meno i pesticidi,
a utilizzare meno i concimi,
avere un impatto ambientale
sempre migliore.
Perché?
Perché noi, i consumatori,
questo consumo consapevole,
questo consumo che porta
alla responsabilità sociale
con le nostre scelte,
indirizza oggi la produzione di cibo.
Perché?
Perché oggi il cibo non è più
un problema di fame,
ma di scelta.
E questa scelta porta a delle conseguenze
naturalmente sul nostro ambiente.
Oggi c’è questo rapporto
sempre più intenso
tra la città e la campagna,
dove anche la campagna si è urbanizzata,
e ci sono modi e modalità di vivere
che sono quelle
diciamo tradizionali della città.
Quindi questo rapporto,
che è cambiato nel tempo,
ha consentito di fare scelte
molto importanti,
che hanno consentito all’uomo,
naturalmente, di avere un rapporto
con il proprio territorio
identitario e sostenibile.
Questo è il nostro passaggio evolutivo
e quindi una produzione consapevole,
oggi, dobbiamo deciderla noi.
Quindi, quando scegliamo sul bancone,
dobbiamo saper scegliere
delle produzioni sostenibili.